what's your name cat got your tongue
we've been fans of all of you Jellico
cats for decades cats is a well loved
Broadway musical after all sure the
storyline is a little strange but it's
entertaining and unique but we have to
admit your cat looks in the 2019 movie
are freaky your human-like faces and
bodies are covered in fur proving that
there might be such a thing as too much
CGI we can't help but wonder if a few
little changes would have made you cool
cats less creepy there's a theory going
around that cats would have been less
creepy if the Jellico's didn't have
human noses baum ballerina
bomble arena is the catnip addicted cat
played by taylor swift many critics have
said she is one of the highlights of the
movie but she looked too human even
though she was covered in fur artists
say did a mock-up of an improved bumble
arena she looks much better with a cat
nose in a furrier face the cat eyes also
helped make her face less unsettling we
think the wild fur all over her body is
a nice touch though the cavity eater
selva plays the mean villain cat going
to the ball could get dangerous say
dropped another mock-up on Twitter
showing a much better Macavity the cat
nose and whiskers are a huge improvement
we also like the wild fluffy look of his
fur it makes him look more dangerous if
you look closely you can see sharp
cat-like teeth he looks much more like a
feral Tomcat in Phase design it really
enhances his villainous vibe
Jenny any dots if the stage musical was
as unsettling as the movie it wouldn't
be such a success but cats started on
Broadway in 1981 the musical is done
without CGI and they really played into
the cat's looks Jenny any dots who was
played by rebel Wilson in the movie
looks much better on stage she has a
well played out eccentric look and the
cat makeup on her nose is really shining
a light on this nose Theory old
Deuteronomy we absolutely love that the
movie gender bends old Deuteronomy this
head of the delicas is usually played by
a man judi dench did a great job but her
CGI was problematic in the original
release
there was a scene with her human hands
the studios sent out an edited version a
few days later we would have loved to
see Judi Dench look a little more like
this version bustopher jones bustopher
jones is the snobby fat cat in the
musical right well that's not going to
work is it that's why I say to you James
Corden does an amazing job acting like a
snooty cat but he really just looks like
a fur-covered James Corden these days
Productions really play up the
distinguished cat vibe his cat nose
leads into whiskers that look like a
handlebar mustache his cat eyes also
helped the feline image we would have
loved to see James Corden look like this
Gus the theatre cat Sir Ian McKellen
really leans into his role as a cat
he's got the mannerisms down pat but his
face just looks way too human-like Gus
the theatre cat is one of the characters
that say fixed up and tweeted out the
added fur on his face really helps make
Gus look less creepy between the eyes
the nose and the whiskers this picture
actually looks more like cat than a
human keep watching to find out how se
drew Victoria monk is strapped Munga
strapped is the narrator of cats he's
one of the Jellicle leaders in the movie
he is played by Robbie Fairchild he
looks like a young kid covered in fur
but he is somehow one of the most
cat-like cast members the 1998 stage
recording makes him look a lot better
he's still a gray and black tabby cat
but his cat-like eyes meshed nicely with
his other features rum tum tugger Jason
Derulo brings the flirty rock-and-roll
Jellicle to life on the big screen but
when you add his sensual moves to his
photorealistic cat face it's a bit
disturbing on stage the rum tum tugger
looks more like a rock star it's so
outlandish that it's less creepy in some
versions rum tum tugger seems to channel
his inner David Bowie again the cat
makeup is crucial Grizabella Jennifer
Hudson as Grizabella is the highlight of
the cats movie she brings her amazing
voice and acting to the saddest role but
the CGI of Grizabella still brought a
lot of criticism the stage versions have
interpreted her appearance several
different ways but she always looks way
less human and it really helps bring the
showed a life and make the character
more believable as a cat Victoria the
newest Jellicle is the innocent Victoria
she is the fourth cast that the artists
say improved on Twitter the movie didn't
change any of her facial features se
gave Victoria real cat eyes the cat nose
is a huge improvement she also makes her
whiskers more pronounced the added fur
also helps cut the creepy factor down
quite a bit
se has done a great job improving some
of the characters and Broadway really
had it right for more videos about all
the hottest movies and television shows
subscribe to the things you can switch
our notifications to never miss another
video if you're watching on your mobile
or tablet
make sure to alter your notification
settings and that's a wrap
do you think the Jellicle should have
had cat noses and what was your favorite
thing about the live-action remake let
us know your thoughts in the comments
section this is what the cast of cats
should have looked like thanks for
watching hit that like button on your
way out
see you next time
you